hello every check nation it's Greg Alva
here this is cat Alvarado
links to her social media including her
Instagram and Twitter which I'm sure you
guys want to follow or in the
description box now you do you know
anyway we wanted to tell you guys that
if you're in New York or New Jersey
you will be performing there in the
month of November next week actually
November 5th through the 9th November
5th in the 6th at 6 p.m. at the Eastvale
comedy clean up November 7th at 8:30 at
the mockingbird November 8th at 8:00 at
2:00 boots Brooklyn and November 9th at
8 at the comedy cove at Scotty's in
Springfield New Jersey if you can't
remember any of that it's all in the
description box for you people and she
performs live comedy stand-up stuff here
in uh LA so you know follow her on
Facebook so whenever she announces this
she'll be performing so we're gonna
watch the trailer today for daddy's home
part 2 so you saw the first one right on
an airplane on an airplane have you seen
the trailers for the second one alright
well do you like Mel Gibson yeah that's
conflicting he's in this one to those
people you have to get to know it
personally to be like act freaking hate
them the official holiday trailer for
daddy's home - this comes out next week
I'm pretty excited actually
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
Jon seda the end
[Music]
[Music]
look adorable the first trailer I saw
looks hilarious second one I was like
add now this one that I'm up at the
point where I'm like I don't care
anymore I just it looks adorable love
the whole cast I just really love the
entire cast
we don't have silly movies like this
enough anymore I feel like because
especially slapstick can be off-putting
now in theatres were so as I notice of
stuff I was even laughing at more of was
like the dialogue driven bits yes as
opposed to like oh then whacking into
stuff or getting hit by stuff doesn't
really make me laugh as much as it did
in the 90s you know I feel like we need
Hollywood if you're listening we need
some new blood like I feel like remember
when in Will Ferrell was in all of the
comedy movies and they were like okay I
get it you just take a sport you put
Will Ferrell and yeah yeah no but you
know a part three of this is gonna be
right the the grandmas the good though
there has to be the woman next right
when would Mark Wahlberg and Will
Ferrell's grandma be I feel like one of
them has to be a serious actress like a
Helen Mirren type or a Meryl Streep okay
that would be will sorrows and then the
other one Helen Mirren is that I do know
what is like Elizabeth Hurley is she
older now she the GHC since the nineties
stay the same age probably the same age
that's a yeah managed men tend to age a
little bit better is the cliche right
like when I look 40 I'll look way better
than you at 40 right now you look better
than me yeah like seven aren't you 38
yeah I look 27 it's crazy but Mel Gibson
man he just cracks me up I like that his
delivery and that his timing I feel like
he'll steal the show in this one
it's gonna be a big surprise for a lot
of people I can't wait to see what John
Lithgow too like he's so he's a staring
door he's it's a rare thing about a
sequel for me is I'm less excited about
seeing Will Ferrell and Mark Wahlberg
comeback and I'm more excited about
seeing John Lithgow and Mel Gibson it
lasts me to was what woman watch this
might be the path to him being accepted
in front of the camera a little bit more
I think yeah yeah some creamy pies in
the face if you are New York go to my
show yeah fly to New York if you're in
LA fly to New York don't wait to catch
her out here know it hey guys subscribe
to the reel rejects I'll be watching
daddy's home - next week I will
definitely be watching this movie I'm so
excited I haven't looked forward to a
comedy and so long like just going to
the theaters and click that notification
bell cat alvarado all social media links
Twitter Instagram Facebook in the
description box make sure to follow her
please and it's the only thing that
keeps her coming back here check us out
on patreon - you become a patron jected
a place
[Music]